[Musik]
ratschläge in die branche mit friedemann
preis mein thema heute altersarmut oder
wie ich es für zdf zuschauer gerne sage
altersarmut wie kommt es in einem
reichen land wird in unseren überhaupt
zur altersarmut die antwort wir haben
alle vergessen vorzusorgen er auch
erlebst du einmal 30 jahren über seine
verhältnisse und schon musst du deine
pokale auf ebay verkaufen
aber keine angst jetzt bin ich hier um
das problem zu lösen
hier sind meine ratschläge gegen
altersarmut erstens share economy nicht
die shell vitalen genau braucht im
altersheim wirklich jeder ein eigenes
teures gebiss nein guten sie ihr lage
bist wenn sie es wirklich brauchen rente
denn das ist der zahn der zeit
zweitens wassersparen im alter nimmt
bekanntlich der harndrang zu daraus
resultieren häufige spiel vorgänger und
das treibt die wasserkosten in die höhe
mein tipp pinkeln sie einfach direkt in
den spülkasten so erschaffen sie ein
kostenloses perpetuum originale drittens
der oma trick richtig gehört den
enkeltrick einfach mal umdrehen
rufen sie bei wildfremden leuten an
hallo hier ist die oma ich dachte du
bist tot
ja genau deswegen die haben mir die
gartenhütte schon wieder erhöht ich
brauche dringend 1000 euro klappt immer
vierter geld vom staat wenn sie wegen
häufigen erinnerungslücken und diffusen
ängsten wirklich nicht mehr in der lage
sind zu arbeiten lassen sie ihre rente
einfach vom staat aufbessern als
volksvertreter es gibt so viele
möglichkeiten
verlinken sie vor der realschule
abgelaufene medikamente oder oder
verkaufen sie ihre
einkaufen gestelle an dono berliner
hitze und nicht vergessen das sicherste
mittel gegen altersarmut ist immer noch
nicht alt werden sie können es ihr
aussehen lassen die einen unfall beim
fand sammeln so das last von mir der
welt gebraucht seine zähne wieder
ratschläge legen die frösche mit
ungenügend region
[Applaus]